DOING A TERRIBLE JOB.
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING ON
ALL LEVELS.
HERE IS FORMER TRUMP CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS AND FORMER
SENIOR ADVISOR TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP STEVEN MILLER.
MARK MEADOWS, SOCIAL FAILS.
THE NEW GREEN NEW DEAL WOULD
FAIL.
OPEN BORDERS AND AMNESTY WILL
YOU SEE HOW THE WORLD IS NOT
SHOWING JOE ANY RESPECT.
THAT'S SCARING ME.
>> WELL, IT'S SCARING ME TOO.
I TALKED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP THIS
AFTERNOON.
YOU LOOK AT THE JOB MARKET YOU
HAVE MORE HELP WANTED SIGNS OUT
THAN IS HEALTHS HEALTHY FOR THE
ECONOMY.
WHERE WE NEED A HELP.
ED SIGN IS AT 1600 PENNSYLVANIA
AVENUE THAT THAT -- THEY ARE NOT
IN CONTROL OF THE BORDER OR OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH CHINA AND
RUSSIA AND NOT IN CONTROL OF
THEIR OWN NARRATIVE.
TLAIB TALKED ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN
DHS BUT WE ARE HIRING NEW IRS
AGENTS AND SEND PEOPLE
DOOR-TO-DOOR TO CHECK ON
VACCINES?
IT'S BEYOND BELIEF THAT
PROGRESSIVES WOULD GO THIS FAR
TO THE LEFT THAT QUICKLY.
>> Sean: WHAT IS THE NET RESULT?
STEVEN MILLER?
>> NO PRESIDENT IN HISTORY HAS
BEEN DEALT A BETTER HAND ON DAY
1 THAN PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THINK ABOUT WHAT TRUMP LEFT HIM
AND WHAT IT'S BECOME.
HE LEFT HIM A MIDDLE EAST AT THE
DAWN OF A NEW PEACE.
THE MOST SECURE BORDER IN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND WE HAD MORE
ENERGY THAN WE KNEW WHAT IT DO
WITH AND AN ECONOMY PRIMED TO
ROAR AND A PATH TO PEACE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THIS WAS LEFT AT THE DOORSTEP
FOR JOE BIDEN.
YOU HAVE CITIES OUT OF THE
CONTROL WITH CRIME AND THE
MIDDLE EAST IN TATTERS.
AFGHANISTAN FALLING TO PIECES.
AN ECONOMY WITH MASSIVE
INGLATION IT.
RUN AWAY SPENDING AND WE HAVE
JOBS THAT SHOULD BE FILLED THAT
CANNOT BE FILLED.
-- THIS IS A DISASTER.
THIS IS LEADING TO AN ERA OF
MALAISE, SUFFERING AND ECONOMIC
STAGNATION.
HE WAGES AND HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
AND MASSIVE CRIME COMING ACROSS
OUR BORDER AND STAYING IN OUR
CITIES.
>> Sean: THE POLL THAT CAME OUT
THIS WEEK, MARK, 57% OF
AMERICANS DON'T THINK JOE IS IN
CHARGE.
58% OF INDEPENDENTS AND A THIRD
OF DEMOCRATS DON'T THINK HE IS
RUNNING THE SHOW.
AMAZING BECAUSE OUTSIDE OF THIS
LITTLE ONE HOUR WE HAVE HERE AND
A COUPLE OF OTHER HOURS ON FOX
AND SOME OF US IN TALK RADIO,
THE REST OF THE MEDIA IS HIDING
JOE'S COGNITIVE STRUGGLES.
WHAT WOULD THAT NUMBER BE IF THE
MEDIA SHOWED AMERICA HOW BAD
THIS IS?
>> I THINK THE ECONOMY IS
ALREADY SHOWING THE SIGNS THAT
NO ONE IS IN CHARGE.
IF YOU REALLY LOOKED AT AN
ACCURATE POLL, THE SPECTRUM OF
THE MEDIA WOULD COVER THIS, WHAT
YOU WOULD SEE THE TOUGH QUESTION
FAILED TO GET ANSWERED BY JOE
BIDEN.
WHEN HE TRIES TO ANSWER THEM, HE
REALLY STUMBLES ALL OVER HIS
WORDS.
IF IT'S SOMETHING MORE DIFFICULT
THAN HIS FAVORITE COLOR OR
FLAVOR OF ICE CREAM, HE HAS
A REAL TOUGH TIME ANSWERING IT.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS INDEED,
STEVEN IS RIGHT.
HE WAS DEALT A GREAT HAND.
ALL HE HAD TO DO WAS SIT IN THE
OVAL OFFICE AND ALLOWED THIS TO
GO ON AUTO-PILOT.
INSTEAD HE PUT PROGRESSIVES
SOCIALIST POLICIES IN PLACE THAT
IS HARMING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: STEVEN, YOU HAVE CHINA
TALKING ABOUT REUNIFICATION.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THEM SAYING THIS
WITH TAIWAN.
>> THEY WOULD NOT HAVE SAID IT
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> Sean: THEY HAD A FEAR AND
RESPECT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> TALKING ABOUT THE TALIBAN AND
THE DRUG CARTELS AND THE
COMMUNIST REGIME IN CHINA THEY
ARE ALL ON THE RUN BECAUSE THEY
DON'T RESPECT THIS PRESIDENT.
THEY DON'T RESPECT THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY KNOW NO ONE IS IN CHARGE.
THESE MARXISTS POLICIES WILL
LEAD TO A STEEP AMERICAN
DECLINE.
>> Sean: I WISH I WAS WRONG IN
POINTING OUT THIS GUY WAS
A COGNITIVE MESS FOR THE SAKE OF
THE COUNTRY AND THE WORLD.
UNDER DONALD TRUMP I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT THE CHINESE WOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT REUNIFICATION
WITH TAIWAN.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE CHINESE AND
RUSSIANS SUPPLYING IRANIANS TO
FIGHT WARS AND IRAN WOULD HAVE
THE GUTS TO START THE ENRICHMENT
OF URANIUM AGAIN.
I THINK THEY FEARED DONALD
TRUMP.
>> WELL, THEY DID FEAR HIM.
THEY HAD EVERY RIGHT TO.
HE WAS WILLING TO CALL THEM OUT.
WE HAVE GONE ON THIS APOLOGY
TOUR AGAIN ABROAD.
APPEASEMENT NEVER WORKS.
OUR ENEMIES RESPECT POWER.
THAT'S WHAT DONALD TRUMP WOULD
SHOW THEM.
THEY ARE GETTING EXACTLY THE
OTHER.
GETTING A CORNATION INSTEAD OF
TOUGH RHETORIC.
THE PROGRESSIVES WERE AFRAID
DONALD TRUMP WOULD LEAD US INTO
A WAR BUT WE HAD A MORE PEACEFUL
MIDDLE EAST THAN EVER BEFORE.
>> DONALD TRUMP WAS THE PEACE
PRESIDENT.
HE UNDERSTOOD PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
WE WOULD BRING OUR BOYS HOME
FROM OVERSEAS BECAUSE WE WERE
STRONG.
WE NEED TO WELCOME THE MEN AND
WOMEN COMING HOME FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
WE NEED TO SAY WELCOME HOME.
>> AMEN, MARK.
>> Sean: MAYBE WE SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN OUR WEAPONS OUT BEFORE
THEY LEFT INSTEAD O